i know that i've talked to you about
your album a lot
i know you can keep going i i i probably
think i'm psychotic at this point
literally every time i see him at the
show i'm like dude i was like i can't
and and this is a testament do you have
a favorite song oh my gosh
i mean um i love i love wild actually
what you're gonna be performing today
but yes um favorite place
i really love i love the whole album
conversation is the dark i love the
whole thing it's so so great
those songs are kind of sexy songs dude
i know that's what i'm saying this is a
testament of how good this album is i
started the show as saying like hey my
personal life is kind of like
and so i'm just saying if this album can
be so great for someone like me that's
really wanting some joni mitchell lannis
morris said at this point
like it's a great album well thank you i
i truly you know
uh we all work in this business and so
we can be a little jaded and cynical
i know i'm never like this with albums
and for another artist to actually care
about your music and listen to it and
love it and really pay attention it
really does mean a lot so i am truly
grateful for your
compliments and they are not getting old
to me okay i appreciate it
um it just makes me happy i love it
[Music]
you